so this when we say cutter you have
obviously five pillars of Islam
you know accepting there's nothing
worthy of worship so the Creator that
happens an earth praying five times a
day the fasting during the month Ramadan
paying the the poor due text it's a cat
and the Hodgdon the six articles of
faith and belief in one God the Angels
the books the messengers the day of
judgment and this is hilarious
Kadir what do you advice do you have for
people who struggle with this they say
they struggle with this you know lack of
motivation saying well at the end you
know God has determined where I'm gonna
be you know and they don't move because
of of this covenant they they can't wrap
their mind around it so this kind of
paralyzes I always told that story you
know first of all you know a clear
warning regarding the subject and I'll
come back to the story that don't
indulge into it if you don't know it
because it can be very confusing to some
Muslim yeah is that statement where Ali
Nadi on he said this is one of the the
secrets of a lawyer a fan yeah other of
civil war in filthy yellow color is the
secret of Allah in his creation yes and
el color is one of the subjects which is
very sensitive why again because it is
associated with the names and the
attributes of Allah and you have to be
very careful we were warned against
indulging into a conversation that leads
a person to question and doubt but there
is a minimum because you coded the six
articles of faith there is a minimum
that every single Muslim must know about
other in order to develop a man you see
again Islam is not a mystic religion
you sit and sit okay I'm gonna believe
in them color and how I'm gonna do it so
you must read the club what other has
four levels you must believe that level
number one you must believe that a loss
of Hannah at Island knew everything that
happened in the past he knows everything
that is happening right now as we speak
detailed in details is not ignorant of
anything in details if a leaf falls down
every time at us ottoman water cut in
he'll die a llama yeah and he knows
everything which will happen in the
future he doesn't have to read a book no
even the hypothetical is the question
what if he knows it yeah because we got
read books to learn Allah knows
everything so this is level number one
you must learn that so if I told me
that's why the subject is related to the
attribute the attribute of knowledge
absolute knowledge
Elmo Hitler who listened to the
attribute of riding Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala committed that knowledge into a
book elementa Allah and Allah Allah
movies in one art don't you know that
Allah knows what's in the heavens and
what's and the earth in Lincoln fake it
indeed this is all written in a book so
the second attribute that Allah
committed that knowledge into what into
a book called the law hell muffled the
preserved tablet which is above the
throne and no one has access no one
knows what's in that book
no one learn a billion more sorry
well a malecon Makar yes not a cent
messenger nor abroad by nearby angel
like Jamaica Islands ravine and so forth
so this is - that's the minimum that you
need to know thrill Rada the will a lost
panel at Alamos will for what
he knew and what he wrote to come into
existence to happen to happen look at
this now after that Allah created us to
make it happen
Allah created us to make it happen so
look at these four attributes knowledge
creation will
I'm sorry knowledge riding will creation
divine world creation for you must
believe that so everything that happens
happens for a reason now we use the
huddle they believe in the divine
destiny to comfort ourselves regarding
calamities or things that happen to you
that you had no control over you
understand but we do not use the cutter
they believe in the cutter to justify
our shortcoming our laziness or our
sinning you're getting that yes you see
so we use cutter and and that's where
faith becomes handy when you go through
calamities man saw mostly button fil
ardi wa la vie I'm fuzzy come Olivia kit
in Kabul e and anymore Seva
any calamity that befallen you whether
in your own self death loss of wealth
loss of children except it's written in
a book before it came before we go back
to the fall a la nuit wrote it willed it
so it's a mercy now for you better
making it to happen yeah a locker and
I'll come back to this point very
million if to have it because you know
it's from Allah yeah so there must be a
good wisdom behind it so the brother
extended his family now and he went on
and the sister is struggling with that
yes it's it's it's for wisdom
it's a wisdom it's always come to this
yeah I'll come to this in a moment so I
just want to focus on this point
so we used the cutter to find comfort
well if you had if a fatherly muslim
hadith abhi hoorah Abu Hurairah love the
allah and the prophet salallahu alaihe
salam says stern billahi wa latasha's
and seek help from allah and don't ever
the space and if something befallen you
were in a Sawbuck I say something wrong
happened to you don't say if I would
have done this this would not have
happened that I could allow any file
together like an academic my lien allow
because if after forum allah shaitaan
will get Shaitaan - in video - question
allah is with them why didn't I do this
why didn't I save my son why didn't I
save my wolf why did I make the right
business decision rather say cut da la
la ma sha Allah Allah has ordained and
whatever he ordained came to pass but
Allah so again the point I'm trying to
make we use the cutter to find comfort
pertaining to calamities hardships
trials and tribulations that's it
because you trust Allah his wisdom that
there must be a wisdom behind and I will
come to this point but we do not use
cutter to justify a sin you are indulged
in involved in as we speak or a sin that
you want to do in the future
here is the story that I wanted to tell
then i sidetracked I used to be an imam
and in Washington DC and Maryland before
going to Colorado
so this brother came and he wanted to do
counseling because of his wife and so
forth so I said to him brother
you know this is years back actually I
was like still starting him and now I
was startup yet come after us or
inshallah let's pray ah sir and then
I'll sit with you so we prayed a sir and
I let the salah and I looked at the
negation behind me I didn't see him so I
said to myself let me go to the office
no some people work and hopefully you
know he will show up if he shows up
Hollis will sit if not then I'll go home
knock knock knock
here here Salam alikoum Shearson after
barakato I'm here for counseling so I
assume that he did not reassess so I
said to him brother why didn't you go
make wudu and Shana Andrea and I wait
for you Jonnie here is the Allah he is
what he said coat Allah doesn't want me
to pray this prayer on Stephen is making
my whole right away you killed that
person do you know what Allah wanted for
you yeah that's exactly what what really
it is so he's using this is what we call
I'm sorry III but this is what we call a
sect in Islam call Jerry yeah catalyst
you know during the time formal hot lava
below and a man stole and he is to
establish the criminal punishment in him
he said yeah Amir al-mumineen
you can establish the criminal
punishment on me because I stole because
I stole the putter Allah it was my
cutter to steal and Omer said I will
execute the Penal planet that criminal
punishment of a thief on you because
earlier because of Qatar Allah - but
quite frankly at this time I was not
very well versed in the subject so I
again that subject is a very sensitive
and if if you go into the subject you
must have the Biddle's you know like
somebody goes with a boat in the sea if
you don't have the right to come back
you get in trouble yeah you got to be
but Subhan Allah Allah subhana Allah has
guided me to make that statement which
later on I found out was deep I said to
him why don't you stand up and go to the
bathroom and make wudu and pray us and
say the same statement that Allah wants
me to pray
hmm that's even profounder yeah it's the
same thing yeah and this is what is
what's in the Quran and so if mmm and up
our host Nathaniel will use you said why
don't you go and make wudu and pray and
say Allah Allah wants me to pray now
your verse because you don't know what
vote for me for you to begin with do you
know what Allah wrote for you well all I
met the scholars they say yeah that
Jubal medrood where a truck will Malu he
is using the unknown as an evidence he
doesn't know it meanwhile he's rejecting
the known that he Allah sent you a
messenger telling you that you should
pray in order to be happy in this world
not depressed and order to go to Jannah
and the hereafter which one should you
take clear evidence or your desires
no one evidence you have a no one ever
known clear evidence and and so you
reject that and use what your desires
well the desire is debase but you're
using and no no no no yeah what Allah
wrote for you yes again we go back to
but when we when we debate with fatalis
will limit it
jedidah Bria when you talk to them about
that stuff they always use a very
interesting hadith what Haslam Oh Harry
a conversation that happened between
adam alayhis-salam and prophet musa and
this is not his right lights this is
authentic supply right because the
prophet told us about when they met the
night of the ascension Adam Musa met
Adam and he immediately said to enter
Adam you are Adam our Father you are the
one who got us out of the garden because
eating off the tree so Adam looked at
his grandson with oh you are moose of my
grandson Allah wrote the Torah for you
giving you the Torah didn't you read in
the Torah that this was written upon me
pay attention here so that the factor is
the people who believe in that sect they
tell you Oh Adam is using the cutter as
what a justification for his mistake
mistake and imagine at the end of this
hadith the Prophet sallallaahu alaihi
Salam actually made a very interesting
statement Fahad jamun Moussa Fahad Jay
Adam o Musa Fahad Jay Adam o Musa
meaning what the Prophet is saying three
times he said three times that Adam won
the debate Adam made a point come to me
now I tell you yes you may use the
cutter as a justification regarding
something in the past that you repented
from because everything is other Allah
permitted it to happen
yes you know like you say well my like I
was you know you know when I was young
you know teenager stuff for Allah and I
was doing this but Allah wrote that with
me that I end up drinking or I end up
doing this Haram stuff but the handle I
repented hamdulillah so using it what
not being boastful about it but you're
trying to let people know that he can be
a sinner but but you cannot use the
other regarding a sin that you're
committing now what I send that you're
planning to commit in the future yes
are you getting this oh absolutely now
let's come to the issue of a loss of
Hannah a tad a willing certain things
that we don't like that Allah new root
willed it and he actually permitted it
to happen you see out of respect we do
not attribute evil to allah subhanaw
taala that is why when we say believing
in Elkader highly he was heavily
believing in another the good of it and
what we consider to be evil the scholars
they say we have two types of evil sir
will not luck absolute evil what does it
mean sir on not luck zero goodness will
come out of it and there is another type
of evil that they call shot wound is be
the best way to translate this in
English purposeful evil what does it
mean you see it evil but the end result
of it will be good it has some purpose
behind there is a purpose behind it
purposefully Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
will never permit the first type to take
place in earth absolutely not
no way only human can do absolute evil
that you you go and do something that
but Allah no never will never permit
and the prophets of Allah Allah Allah
invited us to read every Friday a
chapter called a gaffe in that chapter
there is a story out there if you
reflect upon it it explains this it
sends that message to you what story
mosha undercut you get two individuals
both of them are sent by Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala but with one difference one of
them sees with the eye of divine
tomorrow and the other one is judging
what he sees
based on now you understand they met
together they got on a ship didn't have
money this misaki in poor people giving
them a free ride moosa is sitting on the
ship and he sees a hood taking a tool
and he's digging a hole in the ship for
Moosa because he's judging the situation
now that's absolute evil free ride and
their basic aim what are you doing what
TC l heard has an extension to what
Allah revealed to him why he should do
this he's got the whole picture yes and
that's why look at the word Saba how
many times it's repeated in the in that
segment of the soul I'll I'm a collector
in neukölln to Tatiana a Sabra LM
acrylic in the kilometers not a man a
Sabra haven't I told you that you're not
gonna be patient with me
and that's the issue that that's why
when were when were inflected with a
calamity were supposed to do what right
away alladhina either as Roberta mercy
but I start out to spot pp sent the
patient
Allah will show you the purpose later on
that is why the prophet sallallaahu land
described was so brutally yeah I be
medically shoddy heiresses I am a Muslim
Sabra slight why because of your vision
Allah will make you see the wisdom so
they get off the ship look at this
calamity now we are walking together and
here is some stray light if you like
slightly further goes and he grabs
a little boy under the age of puberty
and he separates his head from his body
this is absolute evil Malthus is the
cattle tariffs and Zakia one of them the
korat Zakia you know we believe as
Muslims that children who die before the
age of puberty are what they go to
Jannah there is actually a consensus
about this there's actually a debate
amongst the theologians you know that
the alemão law school the schoolers who
who teach the us all the fundamentals of
the religion regarding at Fatima
shrieking the children of the mushriks
if they die before the age of puberty
there is a question mark that they could
go to Jannah to because they are not
accountable because accountability in
slam kicks off when when you believe at
puberty but we believe as Muslims that
but he cannot identify you cannot point
that this child and say he's going to
gender he can say that Allah o'clock you
have to do it at least strictly without
any identifying so you consider hitter
who do we consider him a prophet he is a
prophet of Allah and I know some people
don't like this even like mekomo a leaf
open may be the status of our Lee above
this is come on get get alive he said
what my file to Hannah Marie I did not
do this on my own I was receiving
commands from Allah who receives command
from Allah but a prophet you see come on
I mean I understand people are gonna you
know some brothers are gonna resent me
for saying that but listen I love you
and you know that's the way it is shared
they got off the ship
well lawyer I wanna tell you something
Eddie if you want to name the greatest
calamity that the person can be
inflicted with is the loss of your son
or daughter Allah is telling you even in
this one there is goodness I know what I
feel hadith that Allah would send the
angel to someone who lost his son what
is my slave is saying yo Robbie Singh
hamdulillah so Allah will say Abdi my
slave I have two men who failed at the
Kapiti I took a piece of his liver
wife money and he sing hamdulillah
he's accepting it accepting my kebab if
newly activated Fijian knows about what
was a more vital Hammond built for my
slave a house in general call it the
house of praise house it's a great
calamity Allah is telling you even in
this one there is goodness
so Musa because he's judging now what
Hitler did in the eye of now and Heather
has the eye of what divine tomorrow but
again we go back to these brothers and
sister doesn't know all the knowledge of
the unseen allah subhanaw taala gives
certain people certain bits and pieces
of the knowledge because didn't say that
he knows everything in the van no no no
a limb if Allah Allah
maybe he had an ill them and your
problem across who the knower of the
unseen he only gives like our messenger
sallallaahu Selim II was given some of
the unseen the signs of the hour and so
forth felt good there now he knows why
he's doing this
but Musa is judging it now for him this
is a absolute evil shall moot luck
you're killing a baby a child but later
on look at this look at this this child
would he have grown past the age of
puberty he would become a disbeliever
not only this he would have caused his
believing parents to become disbelievers
what is the solution for this for him to
die before the age of puberty goes to
general his parents to maintain their
Eman
not only this for their patients Allah
will replace them with a believing child
happy family at the end Salah story
again had a whole other you know when do
you have to trust the wisdom of Allah
listen Abu Diab thought when you're
inflected with a calamity exercising the
servitude of patience is mandatory a
rather new you accepting it no later on
you accept you know nobody said that you
have to accept it and be happy about
don't don't walk around and oh allah has
taken my son i'm happy no don't do that
no no but patience well in Namur
sovereign doesn't matter
last question